Sit down,
good,
very,
very good.
Gain momentum well.
What I really like is when you're sitting,
you have the belly beautiful in it.
If you stand here,
you are always 1 bit in the hollow back.
Try to stand here right now.
Yeah,
that's exactly how you sit down,
exactly in the position.
Yes, perfect,
yes, very,
very good.
Little bit more backwards.
The knees slide over the toes quite a bit.
Straight,
yes,
very good.
With your hands you press against the mat in the back,
yes,
with your feet you press against the mat in the front
and then yes,
that the hip goes up
and you push them up.
Yes,
this is the final position.
Yes beautiful.
Sitting very quietly
and jump
Mega.
It was super good.
Sitting wasn't quite as good as there,
because your upper body was relatively far forward.
Yes,
you can go a little further.
8.
that you are a bit straighter here,
yes,
but the jump into the position
really great.
Sitting,
a little more backward,
backward, backward,
to the back,
to the back. Yes,
exactly the same.
Try,
when you're sitting up here,
so to speak,
yes n bit
to get directly into this position.
Yes,
for now you have so,
yes,
then you wait,
then you do so and then ah okay,
now I can jump off.
Try
to get there directly and jump right off.
Just so n,
just so n flea.
Could you say so,
super,
mega good,
super here!
You have here,
you are here now
and From the position you go to your other position
and here you try to get everything away,
but it was already very good.
Beautiful tension
I'll span there exactly and now it's going in here.
Just as super!
First you jump up on my hands,
so to speak.
I'll take a little dip in here,
yes,
that it feels safe for you,
you do Me favor,
you're already in a nice position.
Yeah,
you did n great sitting earlier,
yes MH hm and also make n super tense jump
just like before.
Ha ha,
and then you will land super on my hands here.
Okay yeah okay,
let's go
the same and then it's on here.
Super,
now
much better.
Super to the nice excitement here,
think about the shoulder,
let them stand up a little more,
yes,
little more to me,
the shoulder
super,
very good.
Swing up here,
nice excitement in here and out of position.
Nice excitement here,
yes,
From the position it goes here
in exactly exactly,
just uh
and end position,
pull your arms closely.
End position is here,
nice tension here keep nice and bang.
Good good,
That's okay too,
if you make a line there.
Okay, well,
let's start here,
we jump on my arms,
support on the hands
and Cobett.
So last phase,
yes,
everything slowly and in peace for now.
Okay and
Relaxation and further super with break,
and further
exactly then let's.
Now make liquid,
that is
jumps just as AB.
The break here in between is not there,
but it goes directly on.
Yes,
when I say straight on,
but I still want to,
that you think about it.
Hip,
hip,
yes,
only then that yes not
land boom,
but land on your hands.
We stay here.
Reprint,
yes,
that comes one after the other
just as beautiful.
Ha,
did you do your 1st flickflack,
is super,
super,
Very good
hm, okay,
that one wasn't quite as good now.
Head,
yes,
you pulled.
When the head goes,
I had already explained to you briefly earlier,
usually the arms do not come so well behind
and then you get exactly this.
It puts more weight on it,
then you start earlier.
Yes,
these are so sequelae.
Ne yes, 8.
nice again on the head in front,
look there at the back edge,
Long, Long Long,
so that the can pull better.
Yes
really beautiful
before all things.
Now you've really seen everything right.
The head was really nice and straight,
was super
before all things.
The last thing,
so, you waited,
waited and then came only that.
Yes,
that's why the movement went well backwards
here front,
when you jump off,
it's still a bit too high yes,
is also still on the shoulder.
Ha ha,
but which you can also try when you jump off,
to orient yourself a little more to the ground.
So to say, okay,
I don't jump so steeply,
but me.
Try now
to get to the ground faster with your hands.
Yes,
that helps you too,
because actually I found the shoulder at the end,
that is,
the moment you jumped off,
was the shoulder. Good.
Yes,
you do.
You do start here,
but then you come,
you get there and at the jump she is there
where it should be.
But then you make rather there instead of
there.
Think again about the jump to the mat earlier.
Ne,
because that was also 1 bit flatter.
Yeah, right,
not that steep.
Okay, yeah,
better,
yes, yes,
your arms do not pull only once
and then neutral,
but that you pull and work,
work, work.
Yes,
this is important to Me now,
that you are trying to implement this.
Pull.
Yes,
that was better.
Beautiful,
indeed,
that was your best really.
Because you made it front
to have the shoulder here,
then everything else becomes much easier for you.
Yeah,
really good,
beautiful,
very good,
very good.
Likewise,
yes,
very good that you pull your arms further back.
Yes,
not just once,
but move on,
further.
No,
that's the job.
Let's go
Beautiful.
So notice
how important this very first exercise with sitting is.
That's exactly right.
Yeah,
do you really say what's good?
Because that's what I say all the time when you guys in the front
popelig.
But right,
I think that is one of the most important things,
if you do not have this movement in front.
Inside have then it becomes quite difficult.
Super
good good
beautiful.
Overall,
it is still 1 bit steep,
very good,
really beautiful,
Okay,
a little morey,
so a bit more active back to the ground.
Yes,
that it doesn't fly quite that high,
but get to the ground a bit more active.
Yes
super much better,
also beautiful,
very,
very good
go down here well.
Yes,
you do everything the same.
The only thing that changes for you is,
that it's no longer my turn in the back.
That is,
when you get support with your hands
that landing,
you're doing it alone now,
so to speak. Yes
good, good,
good
good,
exactly,
super,
really good.
So I'd say we're going to put an end to that,
or yes best always with good eyes,
really good.
So you can be mega proud of yourself.
Really,
I must say so,
the
was simply n good training.
Yes
I thought,
was really,
really great,
really strong.